l'actualité internationale les cinq
grandes puissances nucléaires
officielles dans le monde se sont réunis
aujourd'hui à genève pour tenter de
définir une attitude commune
après les essais nucléaires de l'inde et
du pakistan afin d'éviter également la
poursuite de l' escalade entre les deux
pays cette tension entre ces deux pays
est perceptible dans une région
revendiquée à la fois par l'inde et le
pakistan
le cachemire qui a déjà fait l'objet de
trois guerres en moins de 50 ans
reportage sur la ligne frontière côté
pakistanais
philippe rochot jean françois renaud
même dans ce village de chénard et au
pied de l'himalaya
on a ressenti lampes de choc politique
des essais nucléaires indiens et
pakistanais pour le cachemire l'inde et
le pakistan ont fait trois fois la
guerre lors du partage de l'empiré des
indes le cachemire à majorité musulmane
aurait dû être donné au pakistan nation
fondée sur l'islande
mais l'inde contrôle toujours les deux
tiers du cachemire côté pakistanais ou
se réjouit donc de la réussite des
essais nucléaires qui permette de
relancer la question du cachemire en
position de force
nous sommes très contents d'avoir ce
programme de battiston grand père est li
a en effet bien nous attaquer en attaque
et notre chambre dans l'airé à talons
nous nous effondrons 1 ou mission une
facel pourtant sur les 1000 km de la
ligne de front où les armées indiennes
et pakistanaises se font face les
violations du cessez le feu n'ont guère
augmenté avec la faire des essais
nucléaires pour le général à berkane qui
nous montre ses positions de l'armée
indienne
juste en face les incidents sont
quotidiens un coup de feu la vie sur la
ligne on n'est jamais tranquille et cela
explique que régulièrement des familles
du cachemire indien viennent se réfugier
au cachemire pakistanais
le cachemire libéré distel le conflit a
fait 60 mille morts ces dix dernières
années dans ce camp où s'entassent une
cinquantaine de familles les gens
affirment qu'ils ont fui la répression
de l'armée indienne qui veut empêcher
les musulmans du cachemire de vivre
libres c'est le cas de mohamed devenu
instituteur pour les petits réfugiés
après avoir pris le chemin de l'exode on
était en train de dormir en paix mais
l'armée indienne a fait descendre tout
le village même fouillé les maisons
c'était l'hiver il faisait froid avait
beaucoup de neige alors pour que le
cachemire soit définitivement attaché au
pakistan les cachemires y sont prêts à
beaucoup de sacrifices
c'est dans cette région du cachemire que
le pakistan avait installé des missiles
capables d'accepter des têtes nucléaires
ils ont été retirés à présent mais le
message est clair le pakistan qui est
parvenu à un équilibre nucléaire avec la
ddt utiliser cette arme pour relancer
une guerre mais aussi pour entamer des
négociations de paix